I'll tell you that sounds like it could
be your transmission or your fuel pump
but we do a complete diagnostic checkup
of your car the clinic yes I'll bring my
limo will ask for me everyone calls me
doc stop by the clinic anytime excuse me
you have a clinic
not just a clinic the clinic we do the
finest diagnostic checkups in town doc
Williams at your service I would love to
talk to you about this problem I'm
having that's what I'm here for what
seems to be the problem
oh no matter what I do I just can't get
going in the morning
that could be your valves really have
you had your pump checked lately by a
specialist I should probably take
another look at it because when that
goes you die right on the spot
do you ever overheat the stall going up
steep hills I don't believe so you
should probably have a major overhaul
check everything inside now do you leak
much several times a day that's no good
is it every place you go you leave those
unsightly puddles yes so your neighbors
cringe when they see you pulling up
their driveway what about your rear end
what about it
does your rear end make noise that's a
bit personal isn't it I'll tell you what
I am up to here in my work but what I
will do I'll lube it up I'll get inside
there and root around and find out what
the problem is I have the best tool in
town trust me I'll do a thorough job in
the meanwhile here's what I'd like you
to do about an hour before you get going
in the morning
drain out your water flush it out of
there completely take in a lot of oil
then grease up that back end get out on
the highway and go as fast as you can
for nine or ten miles really yes
no one's ever said this to me before as
I say I'm a professional I can lick any
rare and problem you can bring me in
fact I do a lot of celebrities too just
last week I reamed out Roger Moore
he was totally satisfied matter of fact
he's coming back next weekend for a
complete rear-end job Oh
when here's some music sure yeah that
could be inspired hot cross buns hot
cross buns one a penny two a penny hot
cross buns Fred Willard is with us fred
is a comedian and actor the way we all
have funny gentlemen dueling from the
red films this is not a Best in Show of
muddy rim and the anchorman movies roses
Emmy nominated walls and Everybody Loves
Raymond and Modern Family I thought you
had those memorized I said I know you
work as well as you do and now you're
just reading no camera
second course hard crossbones yeah I can
notice when your old buddy them when you
can they're not as good when they're
cold hot cross buns hey I know what you
kids are saying am I in the right
classroom who's that new prop in the
fancy duds is it Ricky Martin no it's
just me but you kids are in luck today
because today old Dugan is gonna make
history come alive
I am ma John F Kennedy the president and
I don't like communism very much isn't
that right
Bobby all that is right John it's a good
idea to kill Castro try to kill me
well two can play at this game
operator get me a Moscow Russia mr.
Nikita Kruschev we gave the election to
his brother now he comes after us I'm so
mad I could kill the president
Oh the president's been shot who was it
I guess we'll have to ask Lee Harvey
Oswald
do-do-do-do-do-do-do others my friend
Jack will be hi jack
[Music]
I'm just a patsy and the story ends
or does it is this Jay Leno and no no
Jay retired this is Jimmy Kimmel oh
that's disappointing
mr. and mrs. mcdougal would you like to
begin very well dear Lord we ask you in
this time of turmoil to provide us with
wisdom and compassion that we might act
in accordance with your will amen
I can beat that
Frank we're not competing this is hardly
worshipful oh yeah who made you the
prayer Sheriff I am not the prayer
Sheriff but I will not let you use our
Lord to continue your own personal
arguments it's it's sacrilege you're
right and let's put an end to all this
dear lord please keep this in low family
to hell away from me fine then you stay
the heck away from us - you could say
heck all you want
he knows you mean hell I believe that is
where you're going how about I take you
with me this is just beautiful isn't it
what'd I tell you huh don't get involved
you're gonna come talking and talking
and get people praying love nice job cuz
now we've got ourselves a holy war
I'm out of here president Trump is going
to make outerspace great again no matter
how exactly is he planning to do that
well for starters we're building a big
beautiful space wall and those filthy
neptunians are gonna pay for it what are
you some kind of sensitive little star
flake no like I just I just don't know
why we always need to go to that that's
probably because your mommy hugs you too
much hear what I told them yeah
Malaysian flight 370 is still missing
you know where they're going to find it
the last place they look is this better
now this is a different Malaysian night
here for sure
the pilots last words I've had it with
these [ __ ] snakes on a
[ __ ] plane and it's Adam I know
I'm fine I'm trying you don't hear any
more about in the camera sorry you don't
hear any more about Bob Costas infected
I who is stonewalling this investigation
I'm thinking it all again about a year I
would I would work on my delivery but uh
if if it's not working out so I think
the joke starveling is a better
the consummate amateur package is ready
if you don't want to get down to Miami
Miami Beach we got a great package a
week two weeks oh yeah everything you
need any kind of food and play you don't
you know you get Chinese here and no
need we're talking about Miami now dear
yeah we'd love to go we'd love for a
two-week said you know we'd stop we're
talking about Miami yeah why don't you
put some food on your stomach yes bear
I'll talk what's it like to be with the
circumcised man I'd ask you more about
that but Ronson the whole Jew things cuz
when Ron had his surgery all right all
right all right hey circumcise it while
you're at it you know just cuz I've
never been with anyone else our jury
another minor corrective surgery we have
some coffee at this table please not
minor anymore well maybe you know we
should you know subjects I had what you
know most guys would dream of you know I
and I had to have a penis reduction
surgery
I'm sorry penis reduction which there
aren't many you're gonna say I never
heard of that deserves in many cases Ron
do something and he said why don't you
get one of those vagina in lower arm
it's there come have some coffee over
have you pried the egg rolls
unbelievable tonight let me ask you
something you're a medical man yes I
want to ask you something if you oh you
know I offer for heaven's sake doctor
clear this man not go near dances with
stumpy no quick plug or I'm Mike la
Fontaine owner and founder of high-class
management
look comics constant companion hood it's
a funny that's too dirty let's do a self
to clean it up
opinions are like [ __ ] Neil Patrick
Harris wants to stop opinions are like
[ __ ] in a paradise once this stuff
is talking them oh wait that's just
[ __ ] though in improvising they
teach you they say don't go for jokes
just listen to your partner which I try
to do but occasionally like a Jane Lynch
plays my partner the co-host and she's
you know where I have a story coming up
on blind prostitutes coming up next and
I said you know what they say about
blind prostitutes you really have to
hand it to them
just look forward he was going like this
gee so human to be 21 years old in time
to a vote now the eight oh you're really
18 and so you'd be able to vote and
drink
what's the drinking age in Alaska don't
21 so you last vote silver we need
reading we got to get our young people
into reading I myself have read several
books and so I know how difficult it can
be how many people live in Guam this is
just the MA the plaza nearly 150
thousand one hundred fifty five hundred
sixty grounds there are people from Guam
called what do you say tomorrow no I
need to know today Sun breaks over the
spits oh yeah
Jif she told to me were all
Wall Street semana mourning him Kevin
Boyd call me Tim his nation Farah
Wayfarer away and her main topsails to
the furby though a while a
technical I got an idea a very literate
reference I thought you're familiar with
a book about a pirate captain his name
is Moby Dick
he was chasing us some big whale and he
had a catchphrase Eidos yell out there
she blows so I thought if you could do
that would have some other states drench
the whole group with water and you could
look at the camera and say hey what up
and then every time another thing of
water and by then you're all soaked even
the ladies and at the end of the song
you turn the guitars and all upside down
in water splashes out kerplunk it's a
thought hey leave that cookie jar alone
you deserve a good spanking
where you going after their charge no
I'm okay
all right thank you I'm gonna take you
with me when I climb Mount Everest
that'll be a fun trip might be the first
little guy to be up there have a seat
let me give you a hand here I can climb
in it's fine it's okay I want to help
you somewhere yeah it's okay are you
gonna help me just fine sit down Wow
yeah I can't take my eyes off of you
you're a funny little guy Thanks you'd
make a good mascot actually I am is got
a name's Ron I'm the worm oh you're the
worm I heard talk about you I figure I
think I saw you oh good hope you like
what you saw yeah I sure did is that how
you got to this size huh I mean did they
make you this size just to fit in the
worm costume no they made me this size
when I was born I was oh we're a
legitimate little person yeah I'm not a
fake little person oh I see I thought
maybe they shrunk you down or no
something is it's a very competitive
contest you know yeah I bet I don't
think that technology exists yeah how do
you drive a car do some you sit on
someone's lap or or what no I just
that's a real tiny little car is it tell
me everything this fascinates the hell
out of them I have a pretty standard car
if you have another little person down
there operating the pedals for you no I
basically just have a metal rod that
goes on top of a pedal and there's
another pedal on top of
you just attach it with some bolts and a
wrench and then you have a it's a pedal
extender
that's it you lost me somewhere in there
but I guess it's all kind of I didn't
know if you know who Jack the plumber is
yeah the mascot well I managed him oh
great he's got a wonderful act he's
missing something he's missing a little
button at the end of his act and I got
something percolating in my brain okay
but I need another person it's got to be
a person of your persuasion right so you
want me to recruit a little person
another little person shorter than you
even smaller the better because we all
know each other is that a fact
well our white is one I'll go down into
the tunnel where we all live and blow
into the magical horn that just funnin
me but okay yeah good sense of humor ask
me for five bucks I would like five
dollars now I'm a little short this week
you know